au Kenya cette fois on a rarement vu un
tel mouvement de protestation les femmes
ont décidé d'entamer une grève du sexe
pendant une semaine elles en ont assez
que les hommes perdent leur temps dans
des gu guerres politiques stériles avec
cette semaine d'abstinence forcée elles
veulent les obligé à engager de vraies
réformes dans le pays Claude
sansère pas de réforme pas de rapport
sexuel c'est le mot d'ordre
révolutionnaire lancé par plusieurs
associations féminines au Kenya depuis
plus d'un an le pays est en crise les
réformes n'avanc pas le chômage et la
pauvreté augmentent les femmes ont
décidé d'user de leur pouvoir pour
secouer la société
kenane les femmes du Premier ministre et
la première dame du Kenya sont avec nous
elles nous soutiennent parce qu'elles
sont des femmes l'idée n'est pas
nouvelle dans la Grèce antique les
femmes avaient déjà lancé à plusieurs
reprises des mouvements de Greff du sexe
au Kenya aujourd'hui l'idée suscite de
gros débats dans la rue ce boycotte ne
marchera pas pas pendant les jours
dem parce que les hommes sont en colère
et quand un homme est en colère il ne
peut pas avoir envie de
sex dans la société africaine il est de
notoriété publique que les hommes ont
droit à des rapports sexuels alors si
protest et se ref au hommes je crois
qu'ils vont y prêter
attention devant la presse le
porteparole du gouvernement un peu
embarrassé refusé de faire des
commentaires en janvier 2008 le Kenya
avait connu des affrontements très durs
entre différentes ethnies pour la
conquête du pouvoir depuis les violences
sont cessé mais le pays reste divisé et
les réformes n'avancent pas d'où cette
idée de grève du sexe les femmes
espèrent attirer l'attention des
politiques et les obliger à bouger en
attendant les ventes de revues
spécialisées semblent connaître un joli
succès alors